the yule ball is first and foremost
a dance you might think that battles
monsters and magic spells would have
been the biggest
challenges behind making harry potter
but one unexpected scene proved to be
the scariest of all
the yule ball i think i take the dragon
right now
that's right by the time the goblet of
fire rolled around
the cast and crew were already total
pros at filming those big complicated
action scenes
but dancing dressing up in romance well
that was a whole other story
you'd think that having to pretend to
cast spells fight enormous dragons and
other magical creatures
and survive countless near-death
experiences would be the toughest parts
of acting in harry potter movies
but it turns out that there was one
thing that terrified the actors more
than
any threatening obstacles they had ever
faced before
and that was what
dancing while they all knew it was
coming when it came to having to learn
to not only dance
but ballroom dance during the yule ball
not a single
one of the young actors were looking
forward to it well
that's not totally true according to
emma watson
there was a big difference between the
girls and boys
the girls were all pretty excited to
give it a try but the boys on the other
hand
wanted nothing to do with it the girls
are so eager and
the guy's just not there not wanting to
do it at all
and we don't really blame them not only
did they have to ballroom dance for the
first time in their lives
they had to do it in front of hundreds
of other kids and an entire crew
safe to say they were terrified i think
the kids were all quite scared of having
to dance formally
but no one had it quite as tough as
rupert who
if you remember in the movie had to take
a dance lesson in front of
everyone with professor mcgonagall
herself maggie smith
apparently he felt just as awkward about
it as ron did
because when he sat back down next to
oliver and james phelps who played fred
and george
he muttered to them not to say a word
about what had just happened
so of course they had to poke fun at him
and it doesn't seem like it was all that
easy for maggie either
was pretty strenuous but don't worry
they weren't just thrown in front of the
camera and told to waltz perfectly
they actually had three weeks of
full-time
dance training before they started to
film the yule ball scenes
working with professional ballroom dance
teachers and choreographers
definitely helped them get the steps
down but that doesn't mean they all
turned into many zac efrons
prancing around with all the confidence
in the world oh no
many of the actors still would have
passed on the dancing entirely if they
were given the chance
matthew lewis who plays the notoriously
awkward neville longbottom
definitely didn't relish the whole
experience of learning the complicated
ballroom steps
one bit luckily for tom felton he knew
that he wasn't the only one out there
who was feeling a little foolish
and that everyone around him was feeling
just as silly as he was
so it wasn't all bad while everyone else
was getting the hang of it with weeks of
group training
poor daniel was so busy filming other
scenes that he was actually only given
4 days to catch up and learn the moves
before they were set to film
and not only does he have to dance he
has to dance in front of the
entire school with the other champions
so
the pressure was really on for the young
actors first ever dance scene
luckily harry was never supposed to be
the best dancer in the world
so all of his adorable missteps and less
than smooth moves were totally perfect
for the character at that moment
who was also completely terrified and in
way over his head
finally they did manage to finish all of
the formal dance moments and could move
on to the more fun weird sisters concert
after all of the stress and tension of
making sure that every walt step was
perfect
the whole cast was finally allowed to
really let loose and mosh
for the first time ever at hogwarts and
yet
even that sounds a lot easier than it
actually is
when you're a hundred teenagers in
wizard robes trying to forget about the
giant cameras circling around you
but they managed to totally pull it off
and give the scene the burst of energy
that it needed
one of the things we love about the
harry potter movies is that we got to
watch the characters really grow up over
the course of eight movies and that goes
for the actors too
which is really what set the goblet of
fire apart from all the other movies
that had come before
for the first time the actors and the
characters were teenagers and that
brought on
a ton of changes which became very
obvious when it came time to film the
yule ball the producers and
all the other older actors noticed such
a difference in the way the young cast
behaved around one another
and just how awkward things were
starting to get which they thought was
totally perfect for the energy of the
entire movie
and especially the formal dancing
celebrating the tri-wizard tournament
when you watch the scene and see how
awkward it is for the boys and girls to
interact once they're all dressed up
most of what you see is totally real
when it came to asking cho chang out to
the dance
daniel radcliffe didn't have to work
hard to tap into how uncomfortable it
can be to ask out your crush
and rupert grint actually thought the
acting part was a whole lot easier than
having to ask someone out for real
in real life it's pretty scary
there is really no way for us to talk
about the yule ball without talking
about the awesome costumes that made the
whole thing come to life
the costume designer knew that fans
expectations were going to be really
high for this moment
so she and her team worked hard to bring
a high level of fantasy to the big
screen
and there is no doubt that the entire
cast were really excited to get to
change out of their school robes and
into their finest dress robes for a
night
well almost the entire cast
while everyone else got to dress up and
look their best we all know what
happened to ron
mom sent me a dress and it's safe to say
that rupert grint
wasn't all that happy about it either
but there was
one reveal that did take everyone's
breath away
in a good way when hermione first
stepped out in her pink gown
a lot of fans were a bit disappointed
that it wasn't the blue they had
imagined from reading the book but what
they didn't know
is how many different versions of the
dress were designed
before finally settling on the light
pink one that really suited emma
watson's version of hermione the best
it wasn't all glitz and glamour however
as emma tripped on her long skirt and
almost fell down the stairs on her first
take
i was absolutely terrified once they
were all in costume and ready to go
the actors were brought into the
famously breathtaking great hall
and for a handful of the actors the set
really did take their breath away
the crew had really built huge crystal
icicles that hung from the magic ceiling
brought in christmas trees that stood
multiple stories high
and added a ton of incredibly ornate
decorations on all of the walls and
tables
transforming the already impressive
great hall into the ice palace that
everyone who read the book had imagined
of course
some things in the wizarding world
couldn't be done for real so with the
help of a little bit of cgi magic
the great hall was really brought to
life for the final film
animators added gently falling snow that
never quite reached the ground
a night sky full of glittering stars
above the dance floor
and torches glowing warmly along the
halls in order
to truly capture just how enchanting the
yule ball would have been
all of the hard work that went into the
making of the yule ball from the dancing
to the costumes to the
amazing set that was made even more
beautiful through cgi
came together to create something that
really was
magic after all of that they must have
been thrilled to go back to fighting
dragons in the dark lord
you know the easy stuff but um no it
should be good in the film you won't see
that fair
what did you think of the ewo ball how
do you feel about it now knowing all of
this
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to subscribe to the things to
keep up with all our latest videos